it's my privilege to introduce Michael
kolesnikov who will be presenting today
Michael is pursuing his PhD here at OSU
uh he's an advanced practitioner uh at
the department of surgery with prum and
critical care uh he completed his uh BSN
MSN uh uh and then his nurse
practitioner from San Jose uh and then
came to us and then has done Advanced
certification in um in adult gery acute
care NTI adult genology and acute care
nurse practitioning and today he's going
to talk to us a little bit about the
feasibility of using machine learning
for clinical decision support to
optimize transfusion practice in
traumacare uh and take it thank
you thank you Dr M um first of all I
would like to do some acknowledgements I
would like to say thank you to my
disertation advisory committee Dr Vish M
Dr Karen Iden Dr Martin Shyer Dr Steven
bck and Dr P Abra also thank huge thank
you to faculty and staff and students of
the deise because we've been some some
tough tough times and uh you all have me
thank you so
much uh my topic deals a lot this trauma
and shock and the reason I chose of this
trauma is the leading cause of death in
the age group between 1 and 44 years old
and uh uh we have linked uh shock to the
blood loss A little over 100 years ago
so in 199 in a groundbreaking study came
out and it linked loss of 40% of blood
volume was linked to onset of
hemorrhagic shock today we consider that
class four by Modern Standard because we
kind of moved a little bit in our
understanding of shock and how it
represents hemorrhagic shock still a big
problem it accounts for over 80% of
deaths in the operating room and over
50% of deaths in the first 24 hours
after the
injury um people have been thinking
about blood
trans how do I do
that can't see the
slides there it is perfect sorry about
that all right that sheep very P Yes Yes
actually actually actually the think
yeah so people have been thinking about
blood transfusion since very early time
like prehistoric uh and they've been
attributing blood uh some special
properties like Eternal youth uh and uh
it kind of carries over even into now
now days now first attempt of the blood
transfusion was done in 1667 and it was
done at the same time in two different
countries in England and in France and
both times uh there they used Mally ill
individual and they used ship's blood
and both patients died so since that for
a couple hundred years church has
interfered and they ban the blood
transfusion and that's been going on up
until middle 19th century when uh people
started to think about blood again and
started to do experiments with the blood
transfusions uh they have used blood
transfusions the practitioner started to
use it roughly in
1850 uh for a variety of condition
including mental illness including
tuberculosis so somewhere heat or Miss
and the biggest heat or Miss came out
from our lack of understanding how blood
actually works and the
scientific understanding of blood
transfusion came up in about 1904 in the
beginning of the 20th century when L
stainer developed uh found the um types
of blood that was a groundbreaking
discovery and then we have made the
acceptance uh of blood transfusion chart
so some blood can be accepted but it
depends on your blood type and uh we
consider like zero oh negative BL is a
universal
d uh still even this our understanding
today um transfusion reaction is a big
thing uh we are estimating about between
three to four million of uh transfusions
in
2013 and uh r we have about 11 million
doners and 14 million of blood units
have been transfused in
2019 According to some researchers and
this is the article I have on the bottom
roughly 20% have some reaction to the
blood
transfusion uh it's high uh they
considered even smallest uh needy things
as a reaction to the blood transfusion
most of the surgers would agree it's
more about like
5% um still about one in 20 200,000
cases is a little reaction to the blood
transfusion we also have a blood
shortage in the United States today so
blood supply has been declining since
2013 and that raises the cost of blood
uh one unit of P thread blood sales is
over $200 right now and uh one unit of
platet is over
$500
[Music]
um some resarch and this is the article
on the bottom I believe 92% of blood
transfused patients received at least
one units of uh of blood product
unnecessary and uh this is why I'm
interested in this uh topic so this is a
case of and this is taken from the open
media so we are not breaking any Hipp or
anything like that so this is the case
of uh spring field uh police officer a
in person who was on duty answering a
call and he was shut in his face um he
had struggled uh he he had uh traumatic
brain injury multiple bone factures in
the face and he had lost a significant
amount of blood he was rushed to the
hospital and he actually acquired over
20 units of blood this
year um this is not uh this is not
something uh unusual lots of uh people I
have required massive blood transfusion
protocol to be implemented and this is
just like one of the our own um things
in the you know if you see we got
picture of used units of blood
transfused to one patient and the the
system we have right now is we actually
have a massive transfusion
Runner a real blood bloody IND
individual runs from emergency room to
the blood bank trying to get the blood
on time to the
patient
um if my research is successful I hope
we will be able to identify patients in
the need of blood transfusion earlier
than right now and prevent waste of
blood products and eventually we will
save more
lives before I started to work on this
project I was thinking
well the there are two types of uh
prediction used right now ones are
simple and ones are complex and although
although I did not see them used in the
actual emergency department but I
thought well we probably use the simple
ones so and the simplest of them all is
a shock index so that calls for a
division of heart rate by blood pressure
normally about like everybody who is
sitting here textbook normal will be
your heart rate is 72 your block crunch
is about
um people have difficulties dividing
double digit number by triple digit
numbers on the
stress and period just difficult so
another um assessment of blood uh
consumption uh was it takes into
consideration mechanism of injury
systolic blood pressure heart rate again
so most of them deal with something
simple uh more complex are used um in um
mostly they are used for research
because nobody uses them in the actual
trauma care to determine if this patient
needs the blood transfusion when I was
doing interviews of trauma surgeons what
they told me is we do take into
consideration mechanism of injury and
then we are looking at the actual blood
pressure and heart rate as they approach
each other that's the time we start the
blood
transfusion
um so my research question and
methodology is I'm trying to find
visibility of using machine learning for
clinical decision support to optimize
transfusion practices in traumacare and
I'm propose sequential linear mixed
method study
whatever so my specific aims are number
one I would like to understand how the
decision to do the blood conion is made
my aim number two is I would like to
build several machine learning models
predictive uh capable of predictive anal
itics and number three aim is I would
like to evaluate those models to see how
they
work uh so for the specific aim number
one and I have already started working
on
it uh uh I divide it into three steps in
the step one I would like to identify uh
how patients are identified for the
blood
transfusion uh number two is how we
decide to start the transfusion and
number three how we decided to stop the
blood
transfusion when I looked at the
different transfusion uh different
method identifying patients we need the
blood transfusion I found out about 30
different variables and there are over
24 of them so at 24 I looked and the 25
I said it's not so um there are also
articles which review them all and um
it's about 30 different uh variables
used
they if you would divide them into
categories so some of them are
definitely vital signs systolic blood
fion heart rate is the most common ones
then also changes in the vital science
over
time uh patient characteristics and uh
before I started this research well I
thought well maybe they are all
important but not all of them are
important at the same way so for example
age is important uh height and weight
not so
much uh also La values hemoglobin and
BAS sucess were number
one uh diagnostical Imaging values so uh
people who had long Bor fractures like
fmer and fers and pelvic fractures they
do uh have a more often required blood
transfusion than not and also use of
medications uh such as beta blockers and
um blood blood
thinners The Works trying to predict the
need for the blood transfusion in a
patient population had been done before
and this is a recent article which came
out uh machine learning based
predictions so uh what they did is they
used logistic regression random for and
neural network trying to identify the
patients more into that uh when I looked
in this uh
article they excluded patients who did
not have hemoglobin and the um uh
hematic rate
values uh why I think this is a problem
when patient is acutely injured they
lose lots of
blood uh this blood is the same blood as
they have inside of their body so if you
if you're going to measure the
hemoglobin right at the side of the
blood loss hemoglobin and the body will
be exactly the
same it takes a little bit of time for
the body to do hemodilution and we also
so give uh fluids during the uh
transportation of the patient and that
also accounts for the h delution as well
so the vales of the hemoglobin is L
lagging behind the actual clinical
picture so we have to be able to project
and identify those patients who need the
blood transfusion way before the
hemoglobin uh drop shows on on the
medical
charge uh other than that they did show
this Mo this task was possible by their
U machine learning models and they but
they did have difficulties predicting
massive blood transion because this is a
trauma uh usually and they were uh and I
was not clear how many trauma patients
they actually had on their list I would
I would assume most of them have been
[Music]
excluded now looking at my spe specific
aim number one what I'm am doing is I'm
going to ask clinicians and I'm asking
them already uh about their approach to
the blood transfusion so this is a
phenomenological study so I'm I'm
concentrated on Pat on uh clinicians
experience in one phenomena uh blood
transfusion in trauma trauma
patients uh I'm using two strategies
this is an exploration so I'm learning
the new information and this is ver
verification so I'm trying to verify my
findings as I go about
it uh I'm trying to establish
credibility looking at the similar
researchers uh and
u s uh other data and also doing
triangulation and I'll talk about it in
a second and as far as the
confirmability I'm trying to make sure
the conclusion is actually based in the
data not
uh uh on the data I have
collected so uh about the sampling you
can make an argument this is a
um convenient sampling because I'm going
for the people I actually know I started
there uh you can also make an argument
this is a snowballing because I do ask
people uh for referrals to other um
practitioners who do the same thing I
would like to say this is also purposive
uh sampling because I'm uh limiting my
um uh my subjects to uh people who are
making the decision to transfuse or not
to transfuse the blood in the uh trauma
care in the specific Place uh trauma Bay
uh as soon as the patient arrives uh
from the uh
ambulance so um I'm doing two things
right now so I I did the online
questioner and I have about 13 people
have responded uh I am also doing
recorded interviews and I have done two
bches of them
as I'm going through the interviews I'm
doing coding and I'm looking for the
common themes and I'm hoping to achieve
saturation soon saturation means there
are no new themes come up in the
interviews and I'm doing triangulation
tool so um these are the results of my
um like most important results of my
questioner and they do show mechanism of
injury and systolic blood pressure are
the most important things and as I'm
going into the semi-structured
interviews I'm finding out more about
the relationship between uh systolic
blood vure and other variables for
example um some of the uh respondents
told me age is important and uh the way
age affects the blood pressure is as we
go as we grow older our blood systolic
blood pressure has a tendency to rise
so for somebody who is injured and 18
years old their nor normal blood
pressure will be about 120 over 80 uh
when they come to the trauma PL if there
blood pressure 90 or below systolic
blood pressure we will we will be
thinking about shock and blood
transfusion for somebody who is 75 their
normal blood pressure will be something
about 140 over 90 and as they are coming
into the trauma
Bay the threshold Rises so we will start
thinking about blood transfusion when
the systolic blood thres is about
um as I'm doing this uh interview and
uh online questioner I'm trying to do
the confirmation if the method one
confirms defining from the method two
this uh will be called triangulation and
um I hope I'm on the right track then
I also did some preliminary uh work up
and uh I I used one of the databases to
see if there is a correlation between
blood transfusion and systolic blood
pressure and it came up so as the blood
pressure goes down to 110
approximately uh the rate of the units
transfused to this patients raises
significantly
um
what I'm trying to achieve in all of
this activity I'm trying to construct
the decision domain so if my variables
the ones I discover to be important for
the BL transfusion decision uh will be
converted into dimensions and those
Dimensions will Define the
database uh I should be able to see
those patients who need the block
transfusion don't need the blood
transfusion maybe those who needs the uh
blood transfusion and
um that's that's that's the goal of my
aim number
one my aim number two is building uh
machine uh learning tools for Predictive
Analytics and what I'm hoping to get
there is um using the database I
constructed from my
M1 to be able to predict any blood
transfusion massive uh or uh using
congression maybe uh finding out the
amount of blood needed for any specific
patient my second type of data I'm
planning to use is called time series
and this is a repetitive measurement of
the same
uh same variable over period of
time uh there are a couple of places
where this is done in medicine and one
of them is in the ambulance when the
patient is being delivered from the side
of the injury to the emergency room uh
they report systolic blood pressure and
heart
rate um and uh also um if we are able to
identify the patient but we don't have
the blood available at the side uh that
might be a problem for uh for us as well
so my second uh time series I'm trying
to find out if I I'll I will be able to
predict demand in the blood products for
the future date
and last but not least is I would like
to uh use visual data trying to analyze
it and see if how that corresponds this
the um blood
transfer so choosing the algorithm so
one of them is uh I'm planning to use
multi-layer
pertron and I'm going to talk about it
in a second there are also for time
series I was looking at that there is a
statistical uh type of um data analysis
called least absolute shrinkage and
selection operator last so um we also
have a current neural network and that
currently uses lstm long short-term
memory cells and
Transformers and last for the uh uh
analyzing the visual data I'm planning
to use convolutional neural
network now let's dive into that so
imagine you are uh working at the carel
AR night club and it's 1957 and the
person next to you is his name is France
crosen blood so he is working on
something and if you ask him what he is
doing he would tell you look at the
neuron um I'm using The Cutting Edge
knowledge about neuron and how it works
to make the thinking machine so how does
the neuron Works neuron has a few ddes
they go in and they bring the data to
the neuron something happens in the
neuron and then it either fires or it
doesn't fire on the axon end so um and
what Ren BL came up this is a Petron
it's a simple one layer
Perron instead of the dendroides it uses
data the data points coming in and then
there is a mathematical formula each
data point has weight and bias so it's
multip IED or Amplified
or uh not Amplified and uh there's a
bias added to that and at the end the
neuron either fires or doesn't
fire so uh that was the hype peak of the
um artificial intelligence in
1957 until Marvin Minsky and sear P came
up this a paper in
1969 which showed percep has
limitations and but until then the money
were flowing the defense was interested
we thought we were going to be able to
translate things and do all the
wonderful things that the artificial
intelligence but it showed uh simple
perceptron is capable only to separate
linearly separable
data as you can see it on the picture
and it does only binary classifications
white or black yes or no there is no F50
shades of rate in
between um and that paper called was the
uh AI VN the first one and uh the
artificial intelligence became that word
combination now uh in 19 uh in 1986 what
happened is and that was not the first
time that uh people invented back
propagation what the back propagation
does it looks at how they arri to the
answer and it calculates the arrow and
then using calculus CH it B propagates
weights and
biases in the uh perceptron but it has
to be multi-layer pertron so and then by
adjusting the weight it helps the um
machine to learn data in a different
way so this is why I'm going to use the
multi-layer P if uses web propagation
it's capable of solving complex
nonlinear problems and it also can be
augmented by additional machine enging
protocols uh specific steps I'm going to
use is I'm going to uh use the features
discovered in the first step uh I'm
going to use Caris python library and uh
this is the machine uh the machine
learning tool which I hope you'll be
able to uh learn the need for the blood
transfusion massive blood transfusion
and using cation maybe even predict
specific amount of blood needed for
usion the data set I'm going to use for
this is uh I have been working the in a
trauma service and we are working on one
of the Articles right now so we looked
at the data from 2017 until this year
and we have identified 63 trauma victims
who received the blood transfusion the
topic of this paper is we are
comparing uh whole blood and uh
component uh use of blood transfusion uh
they came up this the idea it's the same
it doesn't make big difference but uh if
I'm able to use this data set and I will
be able to add matching uh P patients
two to one by injury severity score
mechanism of injury and age I'm going to
have about 1900 plus or minus uh
patients in this data
set um I can say this is not much so
this is a modest small uh data sample uh
data set and I will have to use kfold
cross validation now what the kfold
cross validation is uh and what you see
on the picture is a fivefold cross
validation so if you imagine we will
take the whole data set and we are going
to dedicate 20% of it for testing and
validation and the rest of the 80% we
are going to dedicate to training uh the
machine um that we the first step then
we are going to record the uh results
and we are going to do the second
training on the new model but using not
the first but second 20% for training
and validation and the rest of
80% uh for the uh training and we will
repeat this step so this way every
single
um observation or patient in this data
set will be used for testing at least
once well exactly once and uh four times
for
training
um given this is a small data set I
don't know how um good my results are
going to be and my backup plan is using
lights so this is a special um data set
developed uh for linking investigations
in trauma and emergency services this is
a multi- center data it has 70,00 ,000
inpatients uh and
35,000 pre Hospital uh
observations uh there are some uh
difficulties which will uh will be part
of this data as well and one of them is
it's imbalance data set and the reason
for that is we don't do transfusion on
uh even a half of the trauma patients we
do it in about 8 to 12% so and when the
machine is learning what it's trying to
do it's trying to minimize the errow so
um one of the uh interesting things I've
done my um training because I was trying
to train on on a different data set and
the ma said well nobody needs a blood
transfusion because the arrow is only 3%
and this is what you have in the in the
data set um that's not exactly the
answer we are looking for so um for the
imbalance data set there are a couple of
ways I can mitigate this Challenge and
one of them is
uh look at the actual data set and find
out if I can uh do the same two to one
matching between those who did not have
the block concision and those who did
and also using special metrics like
sensitivity specificity Precision rate
and the series operating characteristic
on a curve and I'm going to talk about
those a little bit
later so and uh um next what I'm
planning to do is I'm planning to use uh
um visual data and why do I want to use
it this is a study which came out about
two years ago and this is why I think
injury pattern plays role what they have
done is they looked at couple of
variables and uh they were trying to
determine on a prehospital stage if this
patient needs a blood transfusion or
doesn't need a blood
transfusion so um they looked at the
blood pressure of course everybody looks
at the blood pressure heart rate they
assigned and most of the uh scoring
tools they assign uh a score and they
also looked at the uh trle gunshot wound
injury so when they looked at the injury
they were trying to uh separate the
chest into several different areas and
uh some of them depending on the
underlying structure some of them are
more prone to significant bleeding some
of them less so not all just gunshot
wounds are the same
um as they have done that I was thinking
uh injury pattern actually plays a
significant Ro and uh what I would try
to do is I would like to use
convolutional neural network to identify
this information what's the good thing
about
it well it's um it looks at the Imaging
data uh it looks at the Imaging data
it's capable to use
uh xay
data and we have used the uh we have
used the xay data inition neur net for
chest XDS during Co we were able to
identify those people who have Co Bas
they just explain it that's before the
PCR become
available uh how does it work it uses
steps called um pooling and uh conv
and what it does it extracts it looks at
the picture goes through it several
times and it extracts the features and
then based on those features it gives
you predictions so for example this
picture there is a 20% that looks like
Donald there is uh 10% it looks like
Goofy and 70% it looks like
twey um it's CNN is not a new machine
learning tool it has been used before
many times so
um I'm planning to use it to do uh chest
exra pelvic EXs and uh if possible CT of
chest abdomen and pelvis so because most
of the significantly injured uh patients
in trauma they do get uh CAT
scan uh lastly I would like to look at
the uh feasibility of using the time
series and time series have been used uh
before and uh the Artic below that shows
prediction based on the time series for
the traumatic brain injury
outcome uh how does it work well the
graph you are seeing here that's the
prediction over over several years for
the air uh air travel
demand so uh
as uh there are several uh protocols
which use it they look at the long term
short term and uh what happens currently
in the uh
data um the green lines you are seeing
that's the used for training and the red
lines are for uh
prediction you see the prediction are
kind of little bit off but it kind of
gives you that Trend where it
goes I'm hoping to use it to predict
systolic blood punishment uh heart rate
for the patients who are picked up by
the ambulance from the time they are
picked up to the time they are going to
drop off the patient at the emergency
department because that will help us to
find recognize patients who are going to
be in shock in Shock by the time they
get here and also uh predicting the uh
blood product in the blood bank the data
set I'm planning to use called Nemesis
and this is a very big data
set I I received it I download it I
still I have not tried to open it uh it
has 51 million of uh emergency up
activations um
Point
um My Hope Is it has enough of uh data
for uh blood pressure and uh heart rate
addiction and the second is uh I would
like to be able to predict the uh blood
demand and um that for that I would like
to use the ohu transfusion Services
data what this the what the article
below tells us um the they've been
trying to use two different methods of
prediction the statistical L side and um
lstm uh long-term uh long uh shortterm
memory uh
cell they came up with the prediction
which improved their um usage uh for the
uh platelets platelets is the most uh
most expensive uh blood product uh over
$500 per unit uh I hope I would would be
able to do the similar prediction for
red blood cells plasma and um other
blood
products and my third specific aim is
evaluation of the machine learning tools
what I'm planning to do is I'm uh
planning to use sensitivity and which is
also called theal rate
specificity uh Precision rate
and um the receivers operating
characteristics now how the the Ser
operating characteristics work so we are
looking at the true positive and there
are the Y AIS and we're looking at the
false positives so in the ideal training
uh we should be ending up in the left
upper corner so that will give us the
coverage for the uh 100% everybody will
be identified as true positive rate and
there there will be no false positives
it's a wishful thinking of course
uh the uh training I have done on a
different database uh gave me area under
the Cur of
0.64 uh which is a little bit better
than no skill qualif uh classifier and
no skill classifier it's the middle line
which goes from the left lower to the
right upper corner it shows 50% um of uh
data covered
correctly and uh it's just as good as
flipping the coin what I definitely
would like to avoid is worse than the no
skill classifier
scenario uh what we will learn if this
whole activity happens uh so we will be
able to use the uh to learn which
variables are important for um for the
blood transfusion for the decision
making on the uh whether or not the
patient needs the blood
transfusion uh we will be able I will be
able to build few more models and see if
uh they work and uh in the evaluation I
will be able to see how accurate they
are my time uh my timeline so I I have
passed the IRB I'm at the uh last
portion of the qualitative part and uh
I'm planning next year to do prediction
using the qualitative data that's the
multi layer
pertron then uh next quarter doing Time
series then uh using image prediction
and the last 6 months working on the
dissertation so if everything goes well
sometime about this time of the year
next year I'll be doing the dissertation
defense um there are more details if
you're interested in the um how I'm
planning to to do the uh which
Milestones I should pass to in order to
do this
research
so this is prediction based on the
physiological
parameters um using the time
series Imaging for
prediction and uh I also would like to
say thank you to my family for
supporting me through this
process thank you I'm ready for your
questions
so if I'm understanding what you're
going to do is you're basically going to
try to
model the decision to administer
blood
um am I going to model the decision to
administer blood yes and no because on
one hand yes I'm trying to uh use the
same data to predict if uh this patient
will need a blood transfusion or not but
I'm also trying to augment uh the
decision making so if we are able to
predict the blood pressure for the
patient blood pressure and heart rate
for the patient who is picked up in by
by an ambulance in different town and
being driven to us for 45 minutes if I
can predict whether or not their blood
pressure are going to be at certain
level it will help the clinicians to
make the
decision uh so what you're saying is
that an important element of this is the
time at which these different variables
are
yes and maybe you can help me I don't
know that much about these techniques
why is machine learning
right as opposed
to some kind
ofr you know a more conventional
so the question is why the machine
learning is more appropriate than uh
plain statistical
review okay good question thank you um
part of it is um machine learning is uh
able to find uh to use the um not just
simple regation correlation or multi uh
multivar regation to find out uh this
but it also takes into consideration and
it learns on its own trying to
predict uh the outcome um it takes into
consideration small variations in the uh
uh data as they are and small influences
of one data point onto another data
point because it will be difficult to
use Simple um prediction in multi
prediction
for predicting who needs a blood
transfusion based on age
um and systolic blood pressure alone but
even that you can see we we can't rely
just on the blood pressure we have to
take into consideration how much eight
has weigh on it and machine learning
tools uh would be would be able to do
that another
question how do you know that it would
be value able to give the blood sooner
than when it was actually given for the
patients in dat because I'm hearing you
say you kind of want to you're
interested in this time thing yeah um
and sort of early
prediction um do you is there some way
you can tell from your data set that
people got blood transfusions too
late that's a very good question so we
there is any uh so time matters and the
question you are asking let me face it
so uh how do I know if the uh if we gave
the blood too
soon well it's just that is there value
clinically is there blood transfusion at
an earlier time than what actually
happened in your observation phase okay
so is there a value in the a ble to
predict if the patient needs blood
transfusion is their time value that's
the question okay thank you um yes uh
blood is usually sted Frozen so uh
platelets leave about
no not fro not frozen okay fresh okay
fresh blood okay uh so we uh we should
be able to uh get the blood delivered
from the blood bank to the emergency
room or the patient is suffering from
the bleeding before it's too late for
the patient so we can save the patient
that's that's the real
value I have a question sure it's
actually just a clip side of the same
question um how would you know from your
data set the patient received
unnecessary
blood how would I know if the patient
received unnecessary blood this is a
very good question and
um honestly I don't know unless we do
the predictive model which will tell us
how much blood was patient supposed to
get uh and um compared to the actual
blood products given but training for it
uh I might have to use the help of
experts in the field trying to I mean
looking at every individual patient who
ma identifies too much or too
little if I follow I have the same
question but you had the patient 600
trans 1,20 n trans that's what I'm
planning to use right so maybe like non
transfuse can see whether they have
different are they using the crer
stly the criteria I'm going to be using
is I'm going to match the data set and I
have to match them by certain criteria
one of is injury severity score so I'm
looking at the two individuals who are
equally severely injured about the same
age about the same mechanism of injury
and one got the blood transfusion and
one didn't and I'm trying to find out
what's the difference why I think that's
kind of answer that question
right because similar clinical condition
transs and then the next question is the
Ala right right are they survive those
who also have a higher
okay thank
you I also have question you have a
patient have multiple transf right and
the Very trauma time is the syal
pressure what about later they are
relatively
stabilized and then that time probably
globing become yes that's that's yeah
this is I'm I'm looking at the patients
who got blood transfusion in the trauma
pain so patients uh who are getting
blood transfusion on the trauma words
and I'm quite often do prescribe the
blood transfusion there uh they are
outside of the scope of this study so uh
I'm typically because the prediction are
very simple if the hemoglobin Falls
below seven and the Hem it falls below
21 I'm going to do the blood transfusion
if the patient is symptomatic at the
same time or if the patient is PL
planning if we're planning for the
patient to go under the surgery and we
expect the significant blood loss and
that's the machine learning Tool uh
which was developed before so we can so
you are now going to include all the
follow this just that moment just just
just that moment because this is where I
believe uh we are going to save most of
the patients uh those who would normally
die this in the first golden hour of
trauma
Dr M so I think I find you know DA's
comments really kind of interesting and
intriguing about the potential for
earlier transfusion of patients who who
need it in order to change mortality and
morbidity um but also to me the primary
utility value of what you're doing
appears to be be a more mindful process
of blood transfusion so that we're able
to cut down some of the unnecessary
blood transfusion that patients receive
so so so in order to achieve that M have
you a sense
of of how you will change the behavior
at the point of care so let us assume
that you implement this this decision
support what you know what do you see is
changes in workflow and what do you see
as changes in outcomes with respect to
utilization of G transfusions so the
question is how would I uh change the
behavior at the bedside uh in terms of
the de decision making uh for the to
trans use or not to
transfuse um one of the Articles I've
read it said uh it did a qualitative
study of uh people who are making the
blood transfusion decision and uh one of
the answers was uh when you are
transfusing how do you decide how much
do you transfuse and uh one of the
categories of answers was I will never
order less than two two units of
blood so and I think this accounts for
the majority of the people who got at
least one unit unnecessary so I hope uh
my machine learning tool will show if uh
that second unit was
unnecessary whether or not we will be
change the culture I don't know it takes
a long
time yeah your question was kind of like
how can you actually implement this if
you come up with some kind of prediction
how can I implement it well my question
is feasibility whether or not it's
feasible to develop such a tool uh and
I'm not planning to do the
implementation thank
you so if
just
um the timing uh I was say couple years
ago
we we don't know exactly who they are is
but that was a really
huge to you know traa so they really
everything made BL you know
like so we can issue working then we
don't have enough time to type this pent
patients not here we don't know whatc
and so there are areas that
we we know you know this is how and of
course we know
enough warm up get
ready that's the
part you know so I mean I'm just trying
to think sort of practically right these
data
are entered into the electronic health
record now there's probably some time
lag in in that um I think what you're
saying is is that you could sort of
develop some kind of prediction model
based upon the data that gets entered
into the electronic health record and
then that would at least in form of
blood bank right you've got highrisk
patients coming right and also the time
really get the black two patient so
maybe even just you have a data from 17
to 2023 I think we implemented this fake
medical couple years ago so you may even
see the difference of those timing and
maybe there out but I'm not sure I can
answer that b you know and even the
issue to unit whe they really always use
all we do
have policy how we use that right so
maybe I mean this is more of a question
I guess for one but also for M which is
so you said that it takes time to type
the blood and you don't have that
information because the trauma patient
is coming in does that mean that there's
that you're using a disproportionate
amount of say O
Negative right and that's R we can match
but even that we can't even G so we need
to docum who G
so now we got the medical that at least
we know you know that's how get that
ready up get to the board and then
patient right here
will so yeah that's
to that's why to follow up that I I
think the the emergency like database
you know you have that so that may be
very important data set for for you
because I feel like just 20 2,000 data
set from OHSU might be not be sufficient
because for clinical practice maybe if
you can de use Machine model using you
know larger scale or something just to
see this you know um g w or something on
site and then making a prediction based
on the patients age at s because you
know during the in they may take 45 or
something but still the won't I don't
think the EMS won't have giving blood or
something you they were probably just
doing some sailing or something so that
would be really helpful to predict you
know what I mean because with your large
data set with over the country you know
those people that age that shot wounds
death there you know blood pressure and
then 45 minute they receive that they
the outcome is this patient survived or
patient so that will be in terms of BL
bang I feel that's very helpful if we
can get TI of hey we might have an MTP
coming up in an hour something and I
just feel that that's going to have
practical you know and then down the
where you can do that typing yeah so I
like the more data you have will be even
you're just playing pinpoint some simple
you know systolic or blood pressure or
something that'll be really helpful even
for the
surge thank you yeah that that's that's
very interesting um I mean multi- Center
data usually has a little bit of
drawback because it's a um data hity
people have different practices at
different sites so uh but the the sure
size of it is uh very useful for the
machine learning in in terms of that you
can maybe because of the variation in
inter internal like different B set that
that's you may also use your algorithm
to just p do like simple things because
you
know that probably will be more you know
algorithm is prediction but it's kind of
may have some clinical indications I I
don't know yeah yeah it might thank
you are there any questions in chat
Steve are there are no chat questions
but um if anyone on WebEx has questions
they should unmute them sols and ask
them he jum in or ask them in the chat
and I'll be able to
see uh Michael I'll ask you one from the
qualitative side so you spoke to one of
the needs for This research is there are
multiple models out there now to to
predict the need for or the amount of
blood transfusion and those aren't being
used in practice you talk about a
validation phase that you want to do at
the end of your model to to look at its
sensitivity specificity the receiver
operating curve do you think you might
be able to utilize your qualitative
frame those subjects that you had at the
beginning to help you identify the
factors to also help you give a validity
check to is this model any different
than or better than the current models
that you have right now I get you're not
going to work on the the implementation
but might you be able to use that as
part of your
validation well yeah this is a very good
question thank you Dr hexer uh yeah I I
I think I I should be able to use some
uh qualitative techniqu to compare the
um different algorithms and um get some
human response to that that that would
be very
useful I'm not seeing any other
questions coming in from our remote than
awesome
so before because the pizza that
supposed to be here 11:30 is here now
whole purpose to be
here I guess there was a bridge up and
the driver was stuck behind the bridge
so uh if you feel free to grab plates
and grab pizza and take it with you um
at this point I think the public part is
completed and the committee will just
stay so we'll give you